what do I think of a guy who orders a
flavor latte maybe he's a bit softer
maybe he's a sweeter guy or maybe he's
just a I don't know if I can say pill
the red-eye which is such a waste of two
good drinks combined together to create
one crack during the Frappuccino type
ice blended drinks basically you're just
being difficult when you order for my
cafe using Starbucks sizes you've got no
idea what coffee is like if people were
to just show up and say you know what
I've never had a straight espresso
before can I try it that's what I don't
get a tea for free it does impress me
when people come in and like they just
order a cappuccino makes me feel like he
knows what's good you put Splenda in
anything it's just it's gross if someone
asked me to put splendor in their
cappuccino I think there are more on
when you go into a coffee shop and
you're just personable be friendly and
courteous the entire time that's when I
really appreciate the customer I have a
really interesting conversation with
someone while I'm behind the bar I will
give them a free drink because I'm
enjoying their company and that to me is
what coffee is for you know when
someone's having a rough day just by the
way that they carry themselves and if
you can do anything as a barista to make
that better than great if you're on your
phone it's all out the window hang up
your phone you are inviting me to ask
the person behind you what they want now
I refuse to serve people actually if
they're on the phone no just no